pick up your damn suffering
and bear it
and try to be a good person so you don't
make it worse
well that's a truth
you know
i read a lot about
the terrible things that people have
done to each other you just cannot even
imagine it
it's so awful
so you don't want to be someone like
that now do you have a reason to be yes
you have a lots of reasons to be god
there's reasons to be resentful about
your existence everyone you know is
gonna die
you know you too
there's gonna be a fair bit of pain
along the way and lots of it's gonna be
unfair it's like yeah no wonder you're
resentful it's like act it out and see
what happens
you make everything you're complaining
about infinitely worse
there's this idea that hell is a
bottomless pit and that's because no
matter how bad it is some stupid son of
a like you could figure out a way
to make it a lot worse
so you think well
what do you do about that
well you accept it that's what life is
like it's suffering that's what the
religious people have always said life
is suffering yes
well who wants to admit that well just
think about it well so what do you do in
the face of that suffering
try to reduce it
start with yourself what good are you
get yourself together for christ's sake
so that when your father dies you're not
whining away in a corner and you can
help plan the funeral and you can stand
up solidly so that people can rely on
you that's better don't be a damn victim
of course you're a victim
jesus obviously
put yourself together
and then maybe if you put yourself
together you know how to do that you
know what's wrong with you if you'll
admit it you know there's a few things
you could like polish up a little bit
that you might even be able to manage in
your insufficient present condition and
so you might shine yourself up a little
bit and then your eyes will be a little
more open then you can shine yourself up
a little bit more and then maybe you
could bring your family together instead
of having them be the hateful spiteful
neurotic infighting batch that you're
like doomed to spend christmas with
so then you fix yourself up a little bit
kind of humbly because you know god
you're a fixer-upper if there ever was
one
and then you got to figure out well can
you figure out how to make peace with
your idiot brother and probably not
because he's just as dumb as you so how
the hell are you going to manage that
and so then you've maybe you get
somewhere that way and your family's
sort of functioning and you find out
well that kind of relieved a little bit
of suffering although it reduced the
opportunities for spiteful revenge and
that's kind of a pain in the neck and so
then you get your family together a
little bit and you're a little clued in
then at least a bit because you've done
something difficult that's actually
difficult you're a little wiser and so
then maybe you could put a tentative
finger out beyond the family and try to
change some little thing without
wrecking it it's like our society is
complex and we teach our students that
they could just fix it it's like go fix
a military helicopter and see how far
you get with that it's like you're going
to get to do you're like a chimp with a
wrench whack oh look it's better it's
like no
it's not better things are complicated
and to fix things is really hard and you
have to be like
a golden tool to fix things and you're
not
so and that's the other message of the
west
it's like how do you overcome the
suffering of the of life
and i'm not saying it's only the message
of the west
how do you overcome the suffering of
life is be a better person
that's how you do it
well that's hard
it takes responsibility and i think you
know if you said to someone you want to
have a meaningful life
everything you do matters
that's the definition of a meaningful
life but everything you do matters
you have to carry that with you
or do you want to just forget about the
whole meaning thing and
then you don't have any responsibility
because who the hell cares and you can
wander through life doing whatever you
want gratifying impulsive desires for
how useful that's going to be and you're
stuck in meaninglessness but you don't
have any responsibility which one do you
want
well ask yourself which one are you
pursuing and you'll find very rapidly
that it isn't the majority of your soul
that's pursuing the whole meaning thing
because well look what you have to do to
do that you have to take on the fact
that life is suffering you have to put
yourself together in the face of that
well that's hard
need motivation watch a top 10 with
believe nation hey it's evan carmichael
and i make these videos because you are
probably the most ambitious person in
your circle but you know you're capable
of more and you get that push by
surrounding yourself with the best so
today let's learn from one of the best
jordan peterson and my take on his top
10 grocery success enjoy
rule number two stop wasting time i
stopped wasting time
that helped a lot i stopped drinking
i stopped going to bars i really didn't
spend a lot of time with my friends when
i had young kids in particular i had
friends and i i saw them you know with
some degree of regularity but
where i cut corners was more with
social life outside my family so i spent
a lot of time with my wife and i spent a
lot of time with my kids and i spent a
lot of time on my career and so you have
to make choices and i think those were
reasonable choices i'm not displeased
with them don't abandon your friendships
but
um
but you can certainly look at where
you're wasting time and just stop
doing things that you know to be a waste
of time
so and i did and so i had enough room
for my marriage and i had enough room
for my kids and i had enough room for my
career and you know sort of a
multi-dimensional career and i was
always a challenge to me too to see how
efficient i could get
and you can also
and i've really recommended this for
relatively higher income dual income
couples who are trying to pursue dual
careers kids and marriage you can
outsource you know hire hire a cleaning
lady if you can afford it um
buy restaurant food if you can afford it
etc no you can outsource get you can
have someone do your laundry then you
can concentrate on your marriage and
your kids i know that that
you know is only an avenue available to
people who have relatively high incomes
but people who have dual incomes have
relatively high incomes and so
outsource what's unnecessary so that you
can concentrate on what's necessary i
mean i didn't do that when i was
beginning my career because
when i lived in the united states when i
was in my late 20s and starting my
family we had one income
you'd think a harvard beginning
professor makes a lot of money and i
suppose that's true
in some absolute sense but relatively
speaking you know we didn't have enough
money to buy magazines we we all our
money went for
for housing cost and and the basic
necessities of living i had a car that
was 20 years old 25 years old i think it
was old it was bloody thing the doors
fell apart on the person i sold it to
you know like six months down the road
they knew it was a wreck at that point
but
we drove that thing right into the
ground so i know that's not necessarily
possible for everyone at the beginning
of their career but if you have two
incomes you can manage it
i
concentrated on my marriage and making
time for it i concentrated on spending
time with my kids consciously and i
concentrated on developing my career
those were the three elements of my life
and i had some time left over for
creative pursuits and
and and for friends but
most of it was a matter of getting rid
of
time wastes of any sort you know and i
just pushed that out of my life
you know day after day until i wasn't
wasting any time
or virtually no time and you know i've
asked my undergraduates frequently how
much time they waste per day and general
estimates are like six to eight hours of
time they regard themselves as wasting
like that's a whole career right there
right so if you just stop wasting time
you can do a tremendous amount
especially if you also try to maximize
efficiency and i always found that
incredibly
motivating
you know i'm a motivating
game
how much can i do in the least amount of
time possible that was that's fun to try
to do that as far as i'm concerned i
know maybe you know that's maybe it's
undoubtedly a temperamental thing
but
but if you're built if you're wired that
way that's a great
meta strategy
become efficient i always ask my
graduate students when they were
designing experiments they'd come with a
proposal i'd say to them you know is
there any way you could do this 10 times
faster what would you have to cut what
would you have to change to do this 10
times faster
and
you can learn to do that i also learned
to
force the task to fit the time you know
there's this dictum work expands to fill
the time allowed for its completion
work expands
to fill the time allowed for its
completion well there's a
corollary to that which is
work
becomes more efficient in proportion to
the restrictions of time placed upon it
so if you say
well this could take me two weeks but
i'm going to do the best job i could in
one day
you'd be amazed you could get 90 of the
way or 95 of the way or sometimes even
farther in that day
so that's another way of becoming
efficient you know if you only have 10
minutes to do something that should
maybe take you two hours
maybe you can figure out how to do it in
10 minutes you can get dreadfully
efficient
so
that's very much worthwhile in my
estimation if you want to do a lot of
things what what else are you going to
do
you know
rather than become efficient if you want
to do many things you don't have much
choice but it i found it extremely
entertaining to try to do that
and when i was healthy
i could do a tremendous amount in a very
short period of time
i'm very frustrated that that's not so
much the case now although perhaps it's
coming back to some degree rule number
three learn to listen if i've got a
friend in my life or a you know partner
that i want to encourage to
come out of their place of despair into
a better place how do i effectively do
that without overpowering them or
stifling them or making them feel
inadequate which is sometimes the
consequence of trying to change someone
you love
well
example's good
but then i would say disabuse yourself
of the notion that you know what is best
for this person
you don't not only do you not know you
actually don't want that responsibility
for two reasons
let's say they do what you say
and something good happens to them
well whose victory is that
yours are theirs and if it's yours did
you just steal it
and then let's say they fail
following your advice
well they
pay the price for that
and you can skip away merrily and say
well i should have spoke more carefully
it's like you don't mess about with
people's destiny you do not know where
they're headed now having said that
you do what you're doing in this
interview in this podcast
you ask people questions
real questions you know
like how are you feeling
i'm not doing so good today well
you know
what's up what's going on
and you can't think well i'm going to
ask questions to lead this person in a
particular direction because that's the
same game the same instrumental game you
have to see
what it is that you want to know i see
this when people ask me questions after
my lectures you know now now and then
or during a q a now and then people get
up and they'll ask a real question it's
part of the ongoing dialogue something
struck them they stand up there's
something they really want to know it's
honest question and that goes real well
but
not infrequently someone stands up with
a little prepared speech that's packaged
as a question so i get this from
christian traditionalists fairly
frequently they get up and they ask me
about my religious convictions but
really what they want to do is corner me
into admitting that i should accept
jesus christ as my savior and and join a
particular let's say
denomination it's not a question
it's just a manipulation
and so
your questions like your statements your
question should be honest and
if you ask people questions and you
really listen
they will untangle themselves
and that's partly why people love to be
attended to you know
like
if i meet people on the street you know
i ask them their name
they're all usually flustered when they
come up to me they don't really want to
interrupt me and then they're flustered
and the first thing i do is shake their
hand and ask them their name and i
listen you know not that good at
remembering names but
i listen to it and and they know how to
say their name and so it kind of settles
them down and then it sort of marks them
out as a person against the background
eh
and then if i pay attention to them and
listen they will tell me something in
like 10 seconds that i need to know
because they're they have something to
say you know
and then if you listen people tell you
what they have to say and then you get
wise because you collect all that
and so you want to help someone
well first of all you would decide that
you're aiming towards help right
and and that you do that in the spirit
of ignorance this is what every good
clinician learns is i don't know where
you're headed i don't know what's wrong
with you
this is a hard problem man it's like
what's your problem
i don't know what your problem is
so let's find that out first and then
let's find out
one thing you can ask people this is
actually useful in an argument with
someone you love they're they're upset
with you
what are your preconditions for
satisfaction
now i wouldn't state it like that it's
like
if i could give you what you wanted
right now in the context of this
argument and i wasn't doing it in a
manipulative way what is it that i would
have to say or do that would in
principle satisfy you
and that's a hard question you know and
the person might say well i think you
should apologize and about this and you
know and then i will say
what words should i use
and they'll say well if you loved me
you'd know and i would say no i'm stupid
and ignorant and i don't know
what the right words are to satisfy you
so why don't you give me a hand with
that and all utter them inelegantly and
awkwardly in a good faith demonstration
of my commitment to peace and that won't
be so good because maybe it would have
been better if i came up with it myself
but maybe next time i can do slightly
better
and that works it it
requires the person who's after you
to think through
the question even of
whether there's anything that could be
said or done that would satisfy them and
if the answer to that is no well
probably the relationship is over
but certainly
the person that they're accusing has
been put in an absolutely impossible
position
but usually almost inevitably
if the person meditates on it for a bit
there is something that would satisfy
them that can be negotiated as long as
they're willing to give you the
opportunity to do it
you know stupidly and badly
so
listening man
jimmy carr i talked to jimmy carr two
weeks ago the famous comedian yeah it
was real interesting
um he said comedy is the most dialogical
of of the entertainment forms and i
thought well what do you mean by that
because you're just talk
it's a monologue right now i do
monologues but i pay attention to the
audience right i'm always talking to
individual people in the audience and
watching the reactions and listening to
the audience as a whole so even though
it's a lecture let's say or a talk
i'm watching the audience and responding
so we're in a kind of dance well carr
pointed out that comedians before they
hit the road and this is virtually in
invariably the case
they have their new routines so they're
they're they're corpus of potentially
funny jokes
and then they do 200 shows in front of
small audiences
and
the audience either laughs or doesn't
and if you're listening
you collect all the jokes that people
laugh at if you do that 200 times you
have nothing but hilarious material
but you listened and then you can go out
on the road and that was very
interesting to me because humor is a
mysterious
phenomenon experientially and
conceptually and it's sort of
precognitive and instinctual but it's
also extremely sophisticated then
there's an element of transcendence
about it right because you can laugh at
yourself and that's in some sense the
highest form of humor
and so it's so interesting that we can
criticize and elevate ourselves
at the same time and that we find that
intensely pleasurable
and so a good comedian collects ways to
do that shares them with the audience
and he's listening and so if you want to
help someone
the best way to help someone is not to
give them advice
but to listen to them rule number four
live a meaningful life life has proximal
meanings right
there's the meaning that you
experience when you're engaged in a
piece of art or when you're reading or
when you're engrossed in a movie or in a
conversation
there's the meaning that emerges
within your relationships with people
that you cherish
or are enthusiastic with
there's meanings of security and
predictability
there's meanings of
duty and responsibility and active
engagement with your job and your career
there's meanings of aesthetic pleasure
now
all of those have their value
and each of them has their place and you
know maybe there's a hierarchy of value
there as well so that some of those
meanings are deeper than others
and then you might say well what
characterized the deepest of all
meanings and it would be something like
relationship with the transcendent and
that would establish a relationship
between you and
what's always been conceptualized is god
which is generally supposed to be
something ineffable right it's not
definable but you might think about it
as the central animating
spirit of the age or
the value around which all other values
are organized or the wisdom of the ages
or the
creative spirit that possesses you when
you're inspired or
what grips you
with enthusiasm at a sports event or at
a musical event
all of those things and
we need a relationship with that
and
we find our deepest meaning in that
relationship and if we don't find it
i think if we don't find it in something
that's
explicitly
religious
then we tend to magnify something of
lesser value say something political
into that
to fill the void
so yes life has proximal meanings
without god without eternity but
at the ultimate level something's
lacking
and it's the desire to fulfill that lack
that
and maybe the lack itself that's part
and parcel of the religious instinct
so
you can kill god
but you can't
that doesn't rectify the hunger for god
and then that hunger seeks out
replacements that's how it looks to me
so
and then you know you you might also say
well does that mean you have to believe
in god and
i don't think of
the proper answer to that is that
you need to agree with a propositional
statement does god exist yes
no like does this is this table there
yes
it's not that kind of
relationship it's characterized in the
old testament as a struggle so israel
means those who struggle with god
and
you have to participate in that struggle
and you can do that weirdly enough as a
believer as a non-believer
maybe sometimes more intensely as a
non-believer
the issue might be more paramount than
the issue of virtue and
the issue of
the ultimate orientation
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video
i've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five tell the truth
there's so many rules that are great but
what do you think is probably if if if
somebody was to read those books and
there's one rule that you like this rule
of the 24 i've given you over these past
few years
i you can absolutely not get this one
wrong which rule would that be
tell the truth or at least don't lie
because you can't tell the truth right
because who are you to tell the truth
that's a that's a mighty tall order man
but you can stop saying things that you
know are lies and that will change your
life
if you do that
and it's crazy
well how can you adapt to reality when
you falsify it
and you think well i'm just lying to
other people no you're not
you can't just lie to other people
because what you say becomes you
especially if you practice it
because we build ourselves out of words
and that can be lies in action too it's
like
don't don't say things you know to be
false that's a that's a good start man
and it allies yourself with the truth
and that like how can that be a bad idea
imagine that what is true reflects
reality which is sort of the definition
of true how can
failing to align yourself with reality
work how is that possibly going to work
well you say well i can you know if i
lie i get away with something it's like
no you don't
you i i tell you i swear this is true
in all of my clinical practice
i have never ever seen anyone ever get
away with anything even once
you think the chickens won't come home
to roost it's like
all that that means is you're too stupid
to see
what your lies cause or too blind or too
self-deceptive you just don't see it
and so you don't get away with anything
nothing it's terrifying to actually
understand that
it's terrifying
what if you can't get away with anything
ever you know well that's the judgmental
god fundamentally that's a very old idea
and it's an old idea for a reason and of
course you can't get away with anything
because imagine that you took a
flexible plastic comb you know when you
bent it backwards and you say well
i got away with that it's like well
what's going to happen when you let go
it's going to snap back and hit you in
the face and that's that's life man you
warp the structure of reality you think
you are someone who can warp the
structure of reality with your words
and get away with it
really
no man that should that should terrify
you right to the core of your soul
you're not god rule number six change
your perception your perceptual
structures are determined by the goals
that you have at hand i mean some of
that's that's not completely true
because your perceptual systems also
have limitations right there's things
you can't see or hear even if you need
to so there are limitations built in but
within that set of limitations you're
still trying to tune your perceptions to
your motivated goals and that's also
very useful to think about when you're
trying to understand artificial
intelligence because for human beings
without goals there's no perception
because there's no filtering mechanism
that you can use to determine the level
of resolution at which you perceive
anyway so there's the there's a thing
made of smaller things which are made
out of smaller things and it's so it's
kind of my iconic representation of the
complexity of the world and then you
could think well what is this how can
you see this object and i think if you
just look at it
you can
detect it's like a necker cube you know
those cubes that that are line drawings
that you can see the front of and then
it'll flip to the back have you seen
those
so this is kind of neck or cube like or
at least it is for me in that when i
look at it
my perceptions play around with it
sometimes i focus on the kind of
cross-like shape in the middle and
sometimes i can see these other lines
and then sometimes i'll focus on that
square and sometimes i can see the
little dots there or maybe one dot and
my perceptions are going like this
trying to fit a pattern to it and i you
can kind of detect that when you're
watching it and so i would say well you
have the options of perceiving this in
its full complexity or you can simplify
it
essentially
there's lots of ways you can simplify it
but some of them are laid out there so
you take the complete complex thing you
make a low resolution representation of
it
so that's it's rough that's the rough
area that all those dots occupy that's
the rough area broken down to its four
most fundamental quadrants that might be
how you would look at it if if this was
a map of an orchard and you were trying
to walk from south to north that would
be a useful representation this combines
this and this that's
that's the highest level of resolution
that you can perceive this object at
that's lower resolution than the object
itself
so the first issue is how should you
look at things well that's a problem
that intelligence has to solve so that's
one of the problems that intelligence
goes after and then i think what happens
is we have the thing in itself
and then we simplify it with a
perception
and that's like an iconic representation
and then we we nail the iconic
representation with a word and that's
how we compress the world's complexity
into something that we can manage we
take the complex thing make it into an
icon and represent the icon with a word
and then when i throw you the word so to
speak you decompose it into the icon and
then decompose it even further into the
thing if you can't if you know the icon
and you know the thing and so then we
can use shorthand right because you have
representational structures and so do i
and i'm just tossing you markers about
your representational structures and you
can unfold them that's what you do when
you're reading a novel
because the novel comes alive in your
imagination in your own idiosyncratic
way and it wouldn't if you didn't
understand the references of the novel
right the novelist has to assume that
your basic perceptual structures and
your intuitions and your instincts are
basically the same as his or hers
because otherwise they have to assume
that because otherwise they would be
lost in an infinite regressive
explanation
so and it's problematic
often for example if you start reading
victorian novels you may find that it
takes a while to get into them because
the presuppositions the expectations are
slightly different and so is the
language you have to update the
representations rule number seven decide
to love you have to make a decision in
your life
and this is
this is a decision and i would say that
it's a voluntary element of faith
because it isn't exactly evidence-based
it's more like something you decide
before you even look at the evidence
it's more like you decide to stake your
life on this like you know if you decide
to get married to someone you don't
really do it on the basis of the
evidence that you're going to have a
happy life because you don't have that
evidence you do it you decide that
you're going to make a happy life with
this person and that it's worth the risk
so you you get married as an expression
of faith
okay and and so faith doesn't mean
believing things that no one with any
sense would believe faith sometimes
means putting a stake in the sand and
saying
here's where i stand
in some sense regardless and you do that
when you get married you do that maybe
when you
you know pledge allegiance to a friend
you have a best friend and you want to
maintain that friendship as long as you
possibly can it's it's it's a decision
of faith um maybe you do that when you
decide a career when you go to
university because you could have done
something else right but you chose that
so that's where you put your faith
um and like i said that doesn't mean
believing what no reasonable person
would believe
okay so back to god is love well i'm
going to talk about being first instead
of god
and being is the totality of experience
that we're going to define that it that
way for the purposes of this discussion
being is what there is instead of
nothing and you experience that as a
conscious creature
being is what you experience as a
conscious creature it includes all your
emotions all your motivations all your
subjective experience as well as
everything that's objective
okay so
it seems to me that all things
considered
it's
a useful
move of faith to
act
as if you love being and if you love
something then you want the best in it
to flourish and so maybe you decide deep
in your soul that
it would be better for you to act
towards an end that
makes everything that's good better that
that's the best way to live to make
everything that's good better and maybe
to restrict the development of
everything that's malevolent and evil
within yourself and in the broader world
insofar as you're able to do that and so
i think that's an expression of love is
that because when you love something you
care for it and the proper attitude
towards being i think is care
and so
so that's one element of god is love
god being
analogous in some way to being um
now we could look at god more
classically as the creator of being if
you assume being is good well it's not
much of a leap to assume the creator of
being is good and maybe you adopt an
attitude towards the creator of being
and that's also love and you open your
heart to existence and
maybe that's the most effective means of
having existence open its heart to you
so for example you know if you
love other people you want the best for
them you want the best in you to serve
the best in them if you love them and
you trust them courageously so you open
yourself up to them
i don't think it's unreasonable to
assume that that's how you elicit the
best from them the best that can be
elicited you're going to get hurt
sometimes and betrayed but that's going
to happen no matter what approach you
take i think that's the most effective
approach and that is perhaps the most
effective approach to existence per se
to approach it with love and courage
and
and so
that's
how that looks to me
is it feeling like loving a person yes i
think it is i think it is a feeling like
loving a person it's it's the
generalization of that care that you
would have for
a child your child
your your brother your sister a family
member it's the generalization of that
to the broader
domain of of existence to broader domain
domains of existence and i think that's
a skill in some sense right i mean if
you're
good at loving and caring for your
family but you can
expand that outward so that more people
are brought under that umbrella then
well assuming you can manage that it's
very difficult
it seems to me that that's laudable it
seems to me that we spontaneously admire
and would like to imitate people who are
capable of that
and so you see that when you have a job
or you and you encounter a boss who
takes you under his or her wing and
helps develop you or
you find a teacher who's particularly
inspiring or you work for an
entrepreneur who's inspiring and who
also opens doors for you
they're acting with love as far as i'm
concerned they want the best in them to
serve the best in you and that's very
very motivating for everyone and
that's the proper basis of our social
relationships not power for god's sake
so
can love balance out the crushing
responsibility that's a sophisticated
question
i don't know the answer to that
love is warmer than responsibility love
is the is part of empathy and
agreeableness it's a different dimension
than responsibility which is more part
of conscientiousness than sort of a cold
virtue
i don't know if it balances out the
crushing responsibility but i think it's
the emotional analog to the crushing
responsibility
right so maybe there's love and duty and
they run parallel in in if you're an
ethical person that's not all there is
to ethics but you know love and duty
they're
they're important and and maybe they're
better together than they would be as
independent
um entities rule number eight be
grateful then you could imagine
i have this cottage
in northern ontario and
we're fortunate
uh it's dark there and so you can go
down to the dock at night and in the
clear sky you can see the
vast array of the infinite heavens
arrayed above you you know and it's
something that people who live in cities
really don't get to experience anymore
they don't experience the sunset which
we also go out on our boat and watch
pretty much every day
and that puts you in
in touch with what inspires awe
now and that's not a propositional
experience that's a pre-propositional
experience and it's a deep biological
experience it's
it's
embedded in
the prey response to a predator in part
you know because if you if you feel awe
sometimes you can feel that with music a
lot of people are high in openness to
experience will feel that quite
frequently under the effect of aesthetic
experiences interestingly enough their
hair stands on end that's pilo erection
that's what a cat does when it's
frightened by a dog like the little boy
at the beginning of the story you know
the cat puffs up to look big to be like
medic hats so it can contend with
it can contend with dogs or at least it
could look like it might and so when
when it sees a dog
the sight of the dog calls the best
fourth out of the cat
well that's what happens when you look
at the night sky
you know
he calls to you
right
dr dawkin sent me a paper
last week
in preparation for a discussion that
we're going to have tomorrow and it was
a very interesting paper and i think i
read it about 25 years ago and he said
any functioning
animal has to be a microcosm a model of
the environment
within
within which it finds itself
well
that's true of us
and so when you look at the night sky
and
that
sense of awe grips you and calls
something out of you right to respond to
your encounter with the infant even your
encounter with mortality your encounter
with finitude and limitation all of that
in relationship to the infinite
that sense of awe is also the calling
forth of something out of you that can
respond to the challenge of that
infinite
well that's the microcosm within no it's
a reflection of the structure of the
cosmos itself
that's the divine ideal
and we either imitate that or we fail to
imitate that or we pursue the opposite
path
those are the options you know
and it's
given our technological power and our
capacity for wholesale atrocity
it's time we woke up and realized it
rule number nine overcome self-deception
what's the most effective way of
overcoming self-deception the problem of
self-deception is extremely thorny
and it's tangled up with the issue of
ignorance as well right how do you know
when you just don't know something and
how do you know when you're being
willfully blind and how do you know when
you're outright lying all of those
things are especially to yourself all of
those things are very complicated
so
to some degree the answer is
well you have to
develop a philosophy
of life
that's detailed
that contains within it
an assessment
of your thoughts about the relationship
between
truth and deceit
so
for example
do you believe that it's okay to lie is
it okay to deceive other people to get
what you want are there occasions when
it's okay to deceive other people if
that helps them get what they want so
that would be
an
instance for example of what people
perhaps call white lies right lies that
are designed to be of benefit are they
appropriate
do you feel that it's okay to deceive
yourself or
or other people
in the pursuit of things that you
believe are valuable
and none of those are trivial questions
and
and they can't be
answered with trivial answers so
to some degree you need
a moral philosophy
that privileges the truth above all else
if you wish to cease engaging in
self-deception
and then you might ask well how would
you develop such a philosophy and some
of that might be
well reading about
moral philosophy
reading literature because it often
deals with questions of good and evil
and deception
thinking about it writing about it
reading about it well i said that
and and also contemplating how central
an issue this is for your life how
important is this and
and why is it important if it's
important have you
lied and got into trouble do you believe
that you can lie and get away with it if
you don't believe that you can get away
with it you still engage in it if so why
all right so let's leave the complexity
behind though but but that's a necessary
part of the answer
how do you stop deceiving yourself
assuming that you want to stop doing so
well
i don't believe that you can tell
unerringly when you're telling the truth
i think that some of the time when you
lie outright
you know
and so what i would recommend and have
recommended in my writings in my books
especially in
12 rules for life
the first of my last two books
said tell the truth or at least don't
lie and i added that
codicil to the phrase tell the truth
because it became evident to me when i
was writing that
you know i don't know the truth
certainly not in its fullness
and so
i can't say to someone tell the truth
but i can say
if you believe that the truth is
valuable and if you believe that living
your life according to the dictates of
the truth is for the best for you and
and everyone else let's say
then
you could at least stop
lying
and then
i would say
that
as you
pay attention to what you say
so that you're
attending to your
deceptive statements and trying to stop
making them
some of them maybe you know outright
they're not true some of them make you
feel uneasy and weak that would be a
less
evident criteria of falsehood but still
a reasonable one
you stop doing that
and then
your eye for such things or your ear for
such things or your embodied
capacity to evaluate such things
develops just as everything develops
with practice and your intent which is
to
maintain truth in your speech becomes
sharper
and more focused across time and
perhaps you get
as you eliminate the obvious untruths
you get better and better at
detecting the more subtle untruths and
better and better and better and better
at avoiding being entangled with those
as well
so the first
issue i guess is the decision that
it's best
to live in
truth
and then you have to decide how far
you're willing to take that if that
becomes an absolute for example or if
it's a
you know
an important guideline but
you know perhaps to be superseded by
other things
you have to sort that out for yourself
once having established that then i
believe that you
decide and practice
not lying
and then
possibly if you're fortunate
that the world smiles on you
you'll
engage in less self-deception
i guess the last thing i would add to
that is that there's another form of
self-deception that i wrote about in
my the second of my last two books so
the last one beyond order there's a
chapter in there called don't hide
things in the fog that really deals with
self-deception too so you might say well
there's one form of self-deception that
occurs when
you say something that you know not to
be true and pretend even to yourself
that it's true or even act as if it's
true
or base other statements or actions on
it as if it's true
but there's a more subtle form of
self-deception which i think is more
pervasive which is
the unwillingness
to look at or the willingness to turn
away
from evidence that you know would
undermine something that you want to
believe
or make things inconvenient for you
you know i think like a cliched example
is
maybe someone runs a company and they
have a
chief financial officer and they know
that person is not exactly straight
but it's convenient not to look at the
books
so
maybe when they're around
that person they feel guilty and and
uncomfortable
and that's a sign that you know
something's rotten in the state of
denmark so to speak
but then the self-deceptive act is to
not look
where you know you should look
and
you know that's
the sort of thing that people refer to
when they talk about the elephant under
the carpet or the skeleton in the closet
and sometimes to mix metaphors terribly
it's better to let sleeping dogs lie but
often you know if you have the sense
that there's something more to the story
it's painful and difficult to delve into
it but to not do so
which is the easy route
is
a form of
of self-deception a very common
self-deception
and
i don't think
my experience as a clinician
in my personal experience as well is
that
when you have a sense that something's
up and you fail to act
you almost inevitably pay a much higher
price for it at some point deferred into
the future
so you have to think that through for
yourself and ask yourself if you believe
that's true and if it is true unless you
want more trouble in the future then
perhaps you
investigate when
your moral unease let's say
makes alerts you to the fact that
there's something to investigate and
rule number 10 the last one before some
very special bonus clips is help others
wherever i go in the world people come
up to me and they're usually
i wouldn't say they're happy to see me
they're often in tears
you know
and they often have a pretty rough story
to relate you know they were suicidal or
nihilistic or homicidal or
trapped
desperate
you know and they tell me that real fast
and then they say i've overcome that to
a large degree and thank you for that
and
and you think well that's really
something to
have that happen over and over
in some ways you might think well how
could anything better possibly happen to
you and have people come up to you all
over the world strangers and open
themselves up like that like their old
friends so quickly but
at the same time it's an awful thing
because you see
even in the revelation of their triumph
the initial depth of their despair
so i wouldn't change that
but it's not nothing
and it's certainly not just happiness
it's better than happiness but it's
almost unbearable
if you don't have a goal a transcendent
goal say something that's beyond you
then you don't have any positive emotion
and that's not good because you have
plenty of negative emotion
and then that's that's the problem with
fundamental claims of meaninglessness
too in life that it's this it's the
philosophical error that's made by
nihilists let's say who say well life is
meaningless it's like well
if you're a nihilist
genuinely you've lost all hope your life
isn't meaningless it's just unbearably
miserable
and that's and that's a form of meaning
you know that suffering is a form of
meaning and you can try to argue
yourself out of that with your
nihilistic rationalizations but that is
not going to work you need a
transcendent goal in order to withstand
the slings and arrows of outrageous
fortune
values aren't created they're discovered
and they're discovered through a
consultation with
the parts of yourself that you're not
conscious of that you're not fully
conscious of that aren't articulated
that aren't fully articulated elements
of your primary personality you have to
discover what your values are
and you're informed about that well
partly by other people who will object
if your values aren't appropriate but
certainly by a dialogue with yourself
and with your conscience
that's that's a very important thing to
know it's part of the reason why i think
that you need to tell the truth because
you're forced to negotiate with yourself
to operate properly in the world and if
you've warped yourself let's say or some
elements of yourself by engaging in
self-deception and lies and and you're
not
now because of that you're not who you
could be and you don't live in the world
as you should live in it
then when you discuss with yourself what
your value should be
it will be as if you're discussing it
with someone that you can't trust
and that's
that's not good
like
you you can't afford that
life is
difficult and it contains many pitfalls
and
unless you're careful and you sort
yourself out properly and you aim
high and walk on the straight narrow
path
you don't have a hope of understanding
where you should be and at what time
when
the crisis hits
and the crisis will hit the other thing
you should do if you're not very
industrious
industrious is discipline yourself and
so what do you do with that
eat three times a day at regular meal
times that's a good thing to practice
because that starts to put some
stability into your life
get up at the same time i would highly
recommend all those young people out
there who are listening like you want to
get a jump on life get the hell out of
bed in the morning you know as i've got
older i've got up earlier and earlier
now that's partly because you don't need
as much sleep but it's also partly
because i've got more and more
discipline
like
get up early in the morning and get your
things done man learn to get up at six
in the morning and you'll be one deadly
creature especially if you can get to
work you'll have half your damn day done
by the time other people haul their
sorry asses out of bed and so that's a
massive massive advantage look will
ferrell
warren farrell not the comedian warren
farrell the author he
outlined data in why men earn more which
is a book i would recommend by the way
showing that if you work 13 longer hours
you make 40 more money
it's non-linear so you think why is that
well imagine you had 10 employees and
one of them works an extra 10 percent
it's not much well how often is that
person going to be
promoted assuming you have a clue as a
boss
it's like you're going to look at the 10
people and you're going to think oh that
guy's always here like 45 minutes early
it's like why don't we give him the
promotion obviously
right so these tie these small edges
that you can manage
like that work an extra 10 percent extra
13 percent have non-proportional payoffs
that's part of the pareto distribution
so
get
get your sleep cycle organized so you
get up in the morning learn how to do it
no excuses i'm too tired in the morning
i don't like mornings who cares that's
not relevant it's like discipline
yourself so you can manage it
schedule your meals because that's a
good disciplinary routine
and then learn to use a calendar like
google calendar most of you many of you
out there do not use a calendar okay a
calendar is not a prison and it's not a
tyrant not if you use it properly a
calendar keeps anxiety at bay it makes
sure that you do what you need to do
which is important because otherwise you
fall behind but if you use it properly
though it's also
helps you plan what you want to do so i
could say well lay out your damn
calendar
and
design the days you would like to have
that's what your calendar is for so you
can put in all sorts of things in there
you want to do and that would be good
for you and that's a really good
really good way to start being more
industrious make a plan you need a plan
for three years
you need a plan for the next year you
need to plan for the next six months you
need to plan for the next three months
you need a plan for the week you need a
plan for the day you need to plan for
the hour
all of that all of that i make lists
constantly of what i have to do and
they're like daily weekly monthly yearly
right now i can't look out more than
about six months you know because my
life is too complicated and chaotic but
but you need a vision of who you could
be what character you could have three
to five years out you can't go much
farther than that because life is too
unpredictable i think to
make vision that's longer term than
that subject to
there's too much chance associated with
it to spend a lot of time on maybe you
can stretch it to five years and in rare
cases you can have a 10-year goal but
has to be pretty low resolution but you
want plans at all those levels of
resolution you want to write the things
down and what because what are you going
to do you're going to stumble around and
get get what you need you're going to
stumble around and be useful to other
people and it's useful to be useful to
other people you know they want to work
with you then they want to do things
with you they want to have you around
they trust you they open up
opportunities for you and if you stumble
around like you're blind you're not
going to get anywhere and then you're
going to suffer and then you're going to
be bitter and then you're going to be
cruel
so that's a that's hell that's a bad
outcome one of the things that
distinguishes my work say from the work
of someone like ayn rand is that i make
the case consider continually that
there's no such thing as atomized
individuality and so for for example if
you're going to treat yourself properly
which you should you have to treat
yourself as an iterated process across
time properly so you today you tomorrow
you next week you next month you and
your old you're already a community if
you're going to treat yourself properly
and if you treat yourself properly
you're going to take into account your
family and you're also going to take
into account your community all
simultaneously but the right place to
start is with the things that were are
within your local control and there's
some humility in that it's it certainly
has nothing to do with instantaneous
self-gratification or selfishness before
you can be a painter who can paint
what's beyond mere memory
you you have to inculcate that
discipline skill and a lot of that is
painful repetition and hard grinding
work it's the sacrifice of the present
for the future but once you manage that
then things open up and virtually
everything you learn of value is like
that's very very very difficult to learn
to write and there's arbitrary arbitrary
rules that you have to follow and bind
yourself to and while you're learning
those rules the probability that you
have any creative freedom to speak of or
any facility with the rules is very low
you're you're a rank beginner and and
even to some degree whatever creativity
you have is going to have to be stifled
while you're passing through that that
keyhole but if you pass through it then
something massive opens up on the other
side and it is definitely the case that
disciplinary institutions universities
are exactly that is their places of
guidance and and there are places to
encourage people to develop the
discipline that's necessary to see
beyond the discipline i mean that's why
we have disciplines right i mean the
words aren't there by accident you have
to narrow yourself first and then you
can broaden outward and so that's and
that's part of the process of maturation
that part of that that's part of the
sacrifice of childhood say
in childhood you're nothing but
potential but it's not realized and you
don't know how to realize it and so then
the question is well how do you get to a
point where you realize the potential
and the answer is you sacrifice almost
all of it to a single direction this is
nietzsche's commentary on the catholic
church he's a great admirer of the
catholic church despite the fact that he
was also a radical
critic
critic of christianity said the cat see
the thing about the catholic church is
that it forced
everything to be interpreted within a
single explanatory framework and that
was a discipline
and once that discipline was established
then the disciplined mind could explode
in every direction which is precisely
what happened
and so and and and that's the thing
about growing up is that when you're a
teenager and a young adult you have to
sacrifice everything you could have been
as a child to be the one thing that
you're aiming at but then that opens up
and and the universities are part and
parcel of that process and you need the
guidance because
the
the the library is too large to wander
through it unaided if you really want to
solve a complicated problem maybe you
try to solve it 100 ways
and then you take the best solution got
it and look this happens to
entrepreneurs all the time too you know
like most entrepreneurs this is
something to know well most
entrepreneurs most creative people
fail
at
producing their creative product and
monetizing it right so your default
position if you're a creative person is
you're going to fail
and so and that's because it's hard to
come up with something new and it's j
and it's hard to
present it to the market at the right
time and it's hard to market it like
those things are really really difficult
and so what successful entrepreneurs do
is they just keep doing it over and over
and over and over and over and over and
over and eventually if they're fortunate
one of their ideas happens to hit
the right place at the right time and so
that's also
darwinian in some sense you know you're
creating all these little enterprises
that are sort of alive
they're they're run by people after all
and even if your idea is good that
doesn't mean it will be successful
there's so many things that have to be
taken into account so
this is partly why persistence and
that's part of conscientiousness is so
useful it's like you know what do they
say if at first you failed then try try
again and um and that would probably
mean try something different rather than
the same thing
but
persistence is helpful because it
enables you to run many many experiments
and and you need to know that the
baseline is failure you know it's
important because otherwise you'll blame
that on yourself
in any case people do waste a lot of
time and they are they also act
counterproductively a lot of the time
regardless we do make progress and and
and and we can
thrive
under the difficult conditions that make
up our lives and we can resist the
malevolence that entices us that's
within our power
and we don't know the limits to that and
we also know that
it's better
to
we all know this
that it's better
to live
courageously
than cowardly
everyone knows that that's what you
teach people that you love
and
and we know that it's better to live
truthfully than in deceit
and you can tell that too because that's
also what you tell people that you love
and we know that
you should pick up your damn
responsibility
and move forward everyone knows that
it's it's part of our intrinsic
moral
nature
and that nature is there
and
it's not difficult to communicate to
people about this like
everyone knows
that you wake up at three in the morning
when you've left let your life go off
the rails and that you berate yourself
for your
uselessness and your cruelty and your
failure to take off
to take the opportunities that are in
front of you and if you were the master
in your own house in some sense
the captain of your own destiny if there
was no intrinsic nature well that would
never happen you'd just let yourself off
the hook there'd be no voice of
conscience tormenting you
but no one escapes from that and what
that indicates to me is that at least
psychologically
we live in a universe that's
characterized by a moral dimension and
we understand that well and that moral
failings have consequences and that
they're not trivial they destroy you
they destroy your family they destroy
your community and and
you can tell people that
and they listen because they know
they don't know they know that's the
thing and maybe that's the thing about
being an
intellectual you have the opportunity to
articulate
ideas that other people know they embody
but they can't articulate and that's
what people tell me you know they say
well
you help me
give words to things that i always knew
to be true but couldn't say
or
or they say i've been trying to put some
of your precepts into practice
responsibility being a main one vision
another honesty i i suppose bringing up
the pack and saying this is the fun part
of doing all of this
fun is a weak word that it's it's it's a
it's the remarkable part of doing all
this i mean i have people tell me
constantly wherever i go
it's so delightful that
you know they're in a pretty dark place
and they tell me why and there's plenty
of dark places in the world and they
decided well
maybe they were gonna develop a bit of a
vision and take a bit more
responsibility and start telling the
truth and putting some effort into
something and they come up and they say
well you can't believe how much better
things are you know silicon valley tends
to be liberal everyone knows that and
the reason for that is that there's a
tremendous number of entrepreneurs there
and entrepreneurs tend to be high in
openness and lower in conscientiousness
so they're creative but they're also
willing to break rules you know which
you kind of have to do often
hopefully not to a criminal extent but
you have to
well you know it's tricky when you're
trying to establish something new
because look at a company like uber you
know they had to bend the rules to to be
successful and those companies that have
rented those scooters out and put them
on the streets everywhere you know they
just kind of went ahead and did it it's
not something an orderly person would do
because they'd ask for permission
whereas the people who started these
scooter rental companies just said well
what'll happen if we put them everywhere
and the answer was that seemed to work
but you know
you have to have a rule-breaking
proclivity in order to manage that take
a bit of a look at yourself and think
about what's not so good that you could
improve
that you should improve by your own
standards and that you would improve
you know and set yourself a little goal
um you know maybe you're not studying at
all at
your university
or maybe you're maybe you're at work and
you've got this stack of paper there you
know and you haven't looked at that damn
stack for like a month and you know that
you should be and you're
bothering yourself at night because
you're avoiding that it's like maybe
think i've avoided that stack of paper
completely for one month i'm quite a
coward when it comes to whatever snakes
might be hidden in that stack of paper
how about tomorrow i just like put that
stack of paper in front of me on my desk
and i like
i glance through it for
15 seconds
see if i can do that
it's like well
you set yourself a goal of improvement
you know it's a humble goal because
really are you such a coward that the
best that you can bloody well manage
after a month of avoidance is 15 seconds
of exposure to a stack of paper
you know it could easily be you've been
avoiding it you're obviously afraid of
it and so the situation could be that
dismal and dire
and you might think well geez it's no
bomb to my ego it's no
it's it's no it's not fostering the
strength of my ego to
recognize myself someone who could only
withstand 15 seconds of exposure to that
thing i'm afraid of and so that's a form
of humility too it's like
there's things you could do to improve
and you know what they are
and there's small steps that you could
take that you might take that would put
you in that direction and then the
question is are you big enough to take
those small steps you know are you
capable of grappling with the fact that
your fundamentally flawed to the point
where you have to break things down into
almost child-like steps in order to
manage them and the answer to that is
yeah you are
and that's the lot of
i don't know if it's a lot of everyone
most people have things they avoid you
know and they're afraid of so i would
say to some degree it's the lord of
everyone
people vary in the degree to which
they've conquered that and you do meet
people from time to time who are
extraordinarily disciplined but most of
the time they've got disciplined in
exactly this manner it's through slow
incremental improvement and then you
challenge yourself it's like well could
i do this that would be better
then you find out and then you think
well is there something slightly larger
and more challenging that i could do
that would be better
and and you try it and you find out and
as you try it and you find out generally
you get better at it and you can take on
larger and larger challenges i would say
for the last 45 years we've told
psychologists have been
have been certainly to blame for this at
least in part
you're okay the way you are that's what
we tell young people oh you're okay the
way you are it's
like and there's nothing worse than you
can tell that you can tell someone who's
young than that especially if they're
miserable
you know and lots of them well if
they're miserable and aimless it's like
oh i'm miserable and aimless and
sometimes i'm suicidal and i'm
nihilistic and i don't have any
direction in your life it's in my life
it's like well you're okay the way you
are here and it's like they don't want
to hear that they want to hear look you
know
you're
and you know this you're
useless
you know nothing you haven't got started
you've got 60 years to put yourself
together and god only knows what you
could become
and that's so
that message is so much more it's so
funny because it's so
it's such an attack
but it's so positive
because there's faith there in the in
the potential that makes up the person
rather than the miserable actuality that
happens to be manifesting itself at the
moment and young people respond
extraordinarily well to that because
when you know that if you're a parent
and you love your
your child your son your daughter
what you're trying to
foster
is the best in them you want that to
manifest itself across the course of
their life you want them to become
continually
more than they are to see what they
could be and
well and i think that's part of the
great message of the west is that that's
that's the that's the ethical
requirement of individual
being in in in the proper sense is to
constantly
note that you're not what you could be
to take responsibility for that and to
and to
commit yourself like body and soul to
the attainment of that
ideal you have to negotiate until you
come to the best solution that can be
negotiated which isn't necessarily a
perfect solution but it might be the
best one that can be done and then you
have to stick with it until the next
negotiation and if you get upset during
the negotiations which you likely will
because these are difficult topics how
to divide up responsibilities in the
house and people get mad because they
feel they've been taken advantage of or
aren't being listened to
one of the rules was well you can leave
the discussion but only until you calm
down and then you have to come back
because these things have to be
pushed through they have to be
negotiated through because the
alternative is well important things
don't get done or people
do them resentfully because they're sort
of forced by their own orderliness or
their own conscientiousness or
or
but we know by force psychological or
otherwise on the part of other people
these things have to be negotiated
through
you can tell if you've got
the balance between making peace and
speaking the truth right if the
conversation continues and it can be
emotional and will be and can be
difficult because important things have
to be dealt with but as long as
the people are still in the conversation
and communicating then you then you've
got the balance right you know you might
have to take a break
maybe you have to hold off till the next
day
maybe sometimes when you're negotiating
something that's difficult you have to
offer the other person the opportunity
to sleep on their decision too
which i think is often a very good idea
if you have to make an important
decision in your life it's very
useful to tell the person that you're
negotiating with it look i'm interested
in this and it seems good but i'm not
gonna agree until i sleep on it gives
you
well lots of things happen when you
sleep you organize your brain when you
sleep at least to the degree that you
can organize it and you can often be
more solid or more doubtful about a
decision if you sleep on it there's lots
of ways of defying the crowd let's say i
mean
you could live your life the way that
you want to live it that's a matter of
action
you know and they say actions speak
louder than words and one of the best
things you could possibly be is a
inspirational example
so that's not nothing um
that's that's something live properly
in your defiance of the crowd right
make your own course
allow yourself to be guided by your own
genuine principles you don't necessarily
have to advertise that which is in some
sense what you're doing
when you when you're debating
because you're taking the manner in
which you act like if you're an
integrated person and you're
articulating that
um but maybe you can't do that because
you don't have the verbal skills well
then the question would be maybe you
should develop some more verbal skills
like i don't know this for sure dave you
know but
but generally it's useful how do you do
that um
it doesn't hurt to read
really doesn't hurt to write you know a
little bit of writing every day
clarifies your thinking look it's good
for you to go take your place in the
world have some ambition have some have
a vision have a goal have a strategy try
to try to be a good person in not not
because it's your duty precisely because
that's the proper way to live we're in
danger of undermining all of that and
it's not good for people one of the
things that i've really learned for
example recently is that there's a or
learned to articulate better is that
there's a very tight relationship
between aspiration and responsibility so
let's say well the first question might
be do you need to aspire to something
and the answer is well yes because you
have to do something okay if you just
sit there you'll die you can't just sit
there you have to go act out in the
world okay so act towards what well
that's whatever your aspiration is you
have to have an aim okay well what
should the aim be well it should be
something worth doing let's say what why
do something that you don't feel is
worth doing what do you think's worth
doing well if you watch other people and
you judge when they're doing something
worthwhile you usually judge them
positively if you see that they're
taking responsibility at least for
themselves when you want to be
completely useless so other people have
to take care of you that's pretty
pathetic and maybe you could get your
act together so you're taking care of
yourself and your family and maybe you
could even do better than that and take
care of yourself and your family and
your community you need a value
hierarchy
it's inevitable that you have a value
and that you look at the world through
it and that it should be well structured
and that there should be something of
divine importance at the top i would say
what should occupy the top position is
the realization for example that
each person is of divine value and that
the most appropriate way of interacting
with potential is by
embodying and speaking the truth
that's not a bad way of
briefly conceptualizing what might be
at the highest
pinnacle of the value structure i would
say that's what the logos is
and so
the soul
is
a
the soul is what manifests itself in the
choice between different pathways in in
the choice between different ways of
transforming the potential of the future
into the actuality of the present and it
does that
by making ethical decisions by choosing
between good and evil at each choice
point and to the degree that it chooses
good then it takes the raw potential of
the future
and it transforms it into
the being of the present that is good
and to the degree that it
does that in a manner that's evil and
contaminated by malevolence and hatred
and vengefulness then it takes a pathway
that corrupts the world and makes things
worse
and
it's the soul that's doing that and it's
the soul that's responsible for that
and it's also
that active part of the soul that's
shaping
the deeper soul in some sense which
would be something like the cumulative
consequence of all those choices
something akin to what people
more classically have referred to as
character your life doesn't have meaning
without aspiration or name okay so you
need a hierarchy of values there's got
to be something at the top it's got to
be something important if you don't have
that your life doesn't have any meaning
so if you criticize the hierarchy or
even the ideas of idea of hierarchy you
destroy the idea of aspiration and then
people have nothing
well that's not helpful people are built
for a struggle and they're built for a
weight and you want to take on a heavy
burden voluntarily see if you can put
yourself together see what you can do
out in the world while you're waiting to
die it's an all in game it better be
worthwhile
and so there's a tight relationship
between responsibility and aspiration
and hierarchy when you criticize those
things you get rid of the aspiration
pick something
pick something aim at it as you move
toward it you'll get wiser then maybe
your aim will change that's okay but at
least it'll change in an informed way
it's like discipline yourself in one
dimension
see what happens
well that's exciting
and i think that's something that's open
for everyone
you can do that
i shouldn't say that because i don't
believe that i think you can find
yourself in a situation that's so dire
that you don't there's no escape from it
but
that doesn't matter because
this still this is the hero myth might
not be
the best we have might not always work
but it's still the best we have
and the fact that it might not work
doesn't mean we should throw it away
it's still the best we have
i mean everyone dies and so we fail in
some sense
the fact that a symphony ends doesn't
mean that it wasn't worth listening to
how do i stop ruminating these thoughts
are recurring and relate to every and
any embarrassing moment i have ever had
during my lifetime
i'm a 76 year old woman well oh well
here's something you could try
write down everything that you're
ruminating about
i know that seems counterproductive but
like see ruminations come up
accidentally
involuntarily unconsciously
whereas if you write down everything
that you're ruminating about you're
facing them voluntarily so i would say
well
open up a journal or word document
whatever and write down every time you
ruminate about something
write it down and write down every
rumination you can remember exhaustively
write them all down that would be the
first thing and the second thing is
standard behavioral therapy practice the
second thing the next thing would be
um
write down why you think they happened
so that you get a good causal account
and then write down well what you might
have done about them then
but more importantly what you could do
about them in the future to avoid that
because it doesn't matter that something
embarrassing happened to you once what
matters is whether or not you're likely
to repeat it in the future but my
suspicions are that even if you just
you could just start simply
write down every ruminating ruminating
thought that you have
voluntarily
and and think about them in detail and
write them down in detail get every
little word down
and
then you have that document and then
when you have a thought and start to
ruminate on it um then
sit down later after the ruminating
thought goes away and bring it to mind
voluntarily
so every time you have a thought you
don't want to have
later practice having that thought on
purpose
and try that for about a month
and see what happens because it's often
the case that if you start thinking
about
the thoughts you're ruminating on
consciously and confront them
voluntarily that they will start to go
away i took what i learned about what
happened in the second world war
seriously
it's like wow
we can be really bad
we should do something about that
like that was unacceptable
well was it or not well how unacceptable
was it change your life unacceptable
better be
if you want it not to happen again
and it's not like it the next time it
happens
will make the previous time look like a
picnic
we're way more powerful than we were
you know when we're getting to the point
is something jung talked about
especially near the end of his life
we're getting so powerful that
each individual is now a force of almost
unimaginable destructive power if they
so choose to be
and that's just going to
that power is going to continue to
increase
and what that means is that the degree
to which each of us has our act together
is going to be something
upon which the world increasingly
depends
for its maintenance you see these mass
shootings all the time and everyone does
the same thing oh how did that happen
why did that happen how can it be this
way it's like
well why don't you read what they said
about why they did it and just assume
that that's the reason and if you go
if you go
oh well the columbine kids
oh yeah it was like oh they must have
been bullied oh yes because you know the
natural response of anyone who's been
bullied is to go arm yourself to the
teeth to plot the destruction of the
entire city i think it was of detroit to
line your entire high school avenue with
bombs and then to go and shoot your
classmates that's what happens when
you're bullied it's like no that that's
not what happens when you're bullied
that's a stupid explanation it's shallow
beyond belief and it and it really
emerges only because people don't want
to contend with the real issue and the
columbine kids well they were contending
with the real issue you know they
basically said quite forthrightly that
in their own arrogant estimation being
itself was corrupt and unnecessary and
it would be best if it was eradicated in
the most brutal possible way as fast as
possible
and you get to places like that if you
dwell on revenge for three or four years
in your mom's basement you know you can
go to very dark places
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from bruce lipton
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there you want to
change the world we don't have to
physically go out and physically change
the world first
first we have to change our belief about
the world our belief of who we are in
the world we're not victims